just do it if you've got an idea for
something just do it get out there and
start doing it start small take small
risks don't put all your money into
something but just start doing it
because sometimes we get caught up and
trying to make the perfect plan and try
to have everything mapped out and then
anything that doesn't quite make sense
we have to make sense of it before we
take any action and if you're like that
then you're never going to do anything
because you're never going to have the
perfect plan and as soon as you start
it's always going to change in my first
company was a biotech software company I
spent the whole summer making what I
thought was a great business idea a
great plan and researching everything I
had to have everything figured out
before we really started on it and then
as soon as we started everything changed
I realize my assumptions were wrong that
the market didn't want this at our
customers weren't reacting the way I
thought they were going to react
everything changed and I had to change
and I was so frustrated that I blew my
whole summer working on this plan
thinking this is the greatest thing and
the more time I spent preparing the
better was going to be and it all just
blew up and I wasted all that time so
stop waiting you want something start
start small do something because it
whatever plan you have is always going
to change you're not going to be the
same person in five years you're not
gonna have the same customers it's never
going to work out like you think it's
going to work out and the only way to
get started is to start stop planning so
much get out of your head and start do
something do something today do
something tomorrow keep the energy going
start just do it believe those are
watching like the video give it a thumbs
up below I want to hear your feedback to
leave a comment underneath you have a
question leave it below I love seeing
them come in thank you guys and I'll see
you soon
you